gotta say everybody the Indiana GOP
primary is shaping up as the most
expensive in the nation and it is loaded
with petty insults cotton frog Duluth
the swampers nice to meet you I'm
running for the US Senate Congressman
Luke Messer congressman Todd Rokita and
businessman Mike Braun a former state
representative who campaigns as an
outsider all brand themselves as closest
to the president that's why I backed the
Trump agenda in Congress I'm a pro life
pro Second Amendment conservative who
supports President Trump I was working
with the president to get him elected
against crooked Hillary Clinton Luke
Messer was on the Clinton news network
otherwise known as CNN disparaging the
president the president carried the
Hoosier State by 19 points in 2016
therefore the incumbent Democrat Senator
Joe Donnelly may be vulnerable the seat
could be a valuable pickup for the grand
old party in November however Democrats
say with the nasty campaign the
Republicans are doing their opposition
research for them and Mike Duan this
Democrat raised our taxes 45 times
watchers suggest Republicans have done
so much damage to each other this
right-leaning state is now a toss-up
whoever the nominee is should beat
Donnelly and that's why I was troubling
for the two of them when in the only
public poll they were way off all that
is certain is the White House sees
Indiana as a place Republicans could
gain some ground in the Senate political
wing of the White House is I think
looking at this is the most important
race in the country the White House
official tells FOX News senator Donnelly
is targeted as one of several red state
Democrat obstructionists just two days
after the primary president Trump advise
president Mike Pence are coming to South
Bend Indiana to trump at their own
accomplishments and to boost whichever
Republican emerges from this race Chenin
albeit battered and bruised Mike Tobin
thank you very much